hello YouTube Chuck what are you doing
hello youtubers
coming up cosmic queries on black holes
and dark energy star talk Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
we've got a cosmic queries edition for
you today and I got with me the one the
only
jugnu what's up me oh yeah I filed your
tweets during the Superbowl they would
hail areas oh thanks man
yeah so you were watching the game or
tweeting what were you doing you know
what I only tweeted during the halftime
because I was actually watching the game
and enjoying it and then halftime came
up and I started what and of course it
was very let you know it's very Latino
in every single way and you know I have
a partial Latino household okay so you
know my wife is Puerto Rican and my
mother yeah so my wife's Puerto Rican
and you know so we're sitting around and
the kids and we're all looking at all
the Puerto Rican this happened on your
screen and then we're like yeah this is
great and then it occurs to me they
better get this show over quickly before
Donald Trump's Deportes the whole damn
Super Bowl across the border but cosmic
were today what's the topic
it's black holes and dark energy
I should have sufficient expertise for
that yeah but if not we will get Jan 11
on speed dial I absolutely have to check
in get a little black hole blues
boogie in over oh yeah that's her book
yeah all right should we start yeah so
she's my cosmologists at large yes yes
it's all right I'm sorry we didn't have
her here I love when you guys get into
it man because there's always such great
information that you two you two seem to
it's not quite it's in a physics
language called resonate there's a
resonance excellent yeah yeah that's in
physics lingo okay yes so you have two
waves wait and that one so if they're
not resonating they can actually cancel
out and write nothing exact the peaks go
with the trough correct
but once the peaks go two peaks and the
troughs
then it magnifies the strength of the
wave and they have extra extra flow a
little constructive interference Oh Oh
Chuck remember his high school physics
lab stop right there give it to me all
right here we go
Sunil Engle from patreon because we
always start with a patreon patron
because they give us money and we
appreciate that so Thank You Sunil and
Sonia wants to know this why are we so
sure that there are black holes at the
center of ours and perhaps every galaxy
it could be empty space like the eye of
a hurricane spiraling outwards oh wow
check this out ooh I love me some eyes
of hurricanes right on there was a movie
back in the 60s really you know the Pala
program was fully up and running and so
it influenced storytelling and there's a
movie called marooned in the room yeah
so there was some spacecraft that got
marooned
it's like they couldn't come back down
out of orbit nice and so they had to
Lawton what do you mean nice story it's
great for a story that's all space moves
people go to space and something bad
happen exactly that's the plot right so
so of course it's in Florida you know
this space program launch bases are in
Florida and so they had to ready a craft
to get to them before they died all
right so they've ready the craft and
then hurricane suisse because it's
Florida alright so they can't launch the
hurricane and someone calculates wait
the eye of the hurricane is gonna pass
directly over the launch Tower right but
will there be a launch tower left it was
like very cool that's how I learned that
this Center the hurricane is actually
very silent quiet place right
and so the I came over then they
launched and you see the the rocket
coming out from the center of the thing
so what they're asking is in this
question what Sunil Sunil is asking is
we see all this activity in the center
of the galaxy stars orbiting a big dark
area right how do we know it's not just
like
the center of a hurricane and the reason
why we know that is because what we
learned from Kepler and later Newton is
the orbit that you have is the speed of
your orbit is completely determined by
the mass that's sitting inside your
orbit ha the mess around which you
revolve right so what you say is here
are these things I can see how fast
they're moving run back to Kepler's
equation and say there must be a mass or
a huge mass huge massive the orbit Wow
well it and then you say but wait a
minute we don't know anything that's
that massive that's smaller than the
orbit except for a black hole God said
okay so in other words if it was a star
with that much mass it would be huge or
some other thing and you see it's it a
glowing thing
this is dark and it has huge mass and
it's small mmm that's three smoking guns
right there right implicating a
supermassive black hole supermassive
black hole yes then and our black hole
is less massive than the one in the
center of the Andromeda galaxy our
nearest big galaxy we have black hole
Envy I think we do the black hole so but
we talked about hundreds of millions of
times the mass of the Sun but it's a
black hole so it's small for that much
mass and so that's why I do it so we do
it for our galaxy then we do it for a
neighboring galaxy
go ahead we can't no other galaxies are
far away so ground-based telescopes
there you can't see it so we sent up
Hubble mm-hmm and so we say well if we
have it and we're not really a special
galaxy in the universe and Andromeda has
it our nearest neighbor maybe this is
astronomy astronomy think these two
galaxies have it maybe every house yes
right okay because why should we be
special right it's called the Copernican
principle you're probably not special
right it's exactly Copernicus better
known as my father nice especially I
don't know what you think we'll go ahead
your father interacting with you so so
you we we hypothesize that maybe all
gower
these have black holes so you invoke
Hubble who can see farther away galaxies
and measure the movements of stars down
deep in the middle and they were moving
fast too right and every next galaxy and
so we've now done enough
we're just resigned to the fact that
every gal she's got about even some of
the smaller galaxies that might not have
they got black holes still have black
clothes right so no we haven't seen we
haven't measured every one of the
hundred billion galaxies in the universe
but every galaxy if we measured the big
ones the small one with a it's like
taking a poll yeah except even better
right because the universe doesn't have
weird people living in back roads who
think weird stuff might the universe
could have some weird galaxies that
we've never discovered before right
every galaxy that fits into a category
of galaxies that we've observed it's got
a black hole of different masses and the
more massive the entire galaxy right
then the more mass of the black hole is
that's here yeah there's some that have
billions of times the mass of the Sun as
a black hole sitting in the middle Wow
yeah dated for it really is it's a great
great movie and seen deliverance
deliverance that's right that movie was
so great I have on purpose never seen it
a second time because it was so
disturbing it is a disturbing the most
disturbing but I've ever seen in my life
it's it's delivering really yeah and had
which is why I have it on a loop that
explains Chuck okay that explains it so
that had Ned Beatty it had had a Burt
Reynolds yeah in a serious role yeah at
a time he was making comedies that's
right it's very super cool really good
all right I guess we'll move on away why
not to another page it took way too long
to answer that that's not true right I
know you always want to answer we took a
poll we took a definitive poll yes we
did and you know what they said what
they said so these folks have we want to
keep the long answers right other people
said no we want more questions this is
true but guess what that's right now
nobody wants that though there's always
gonna be people who are like I love your
long answers I it's entertaining I find
out stuff you know that I otherwise
would learn about the
marooned from 1968 how am i ten years
old I have hurricanes a quiet place as
far as I'm concerned oh those are that's
what makes the show good but all right
and here's the thing people and and just
listen to me I'm just a good point
here's the point what we're going to get
to your question at some point at
somewhere here's the thing at some point
you raise an interesting point if I just
gave answers then you don't really need
me know you just be black Google so
these are not Google answer eyes are
sort of fleshy
notice like again I'm just dating myself
here in the old days when you look
something up you're going encyclopedia
that's right but you never it would take
you an hour to get to the thing you
would look it up right because you shut
up there was a whole journey yes to find
your answer and see kids this is what
you're missing out on by not having an
encyclopedia because that experience you
just said right there is one of the best
things in the world it is you go look up
in your world same same with same with
dictionaries right you get obstreperous
right no and that's the front of it and
this is kind of what we're doing so all
right all right here we go
Alex wants to know this you were worried
yeah yeah everything every time I hear
Omaha all I think of is Peyton Manning
kind of smart but yeah no he's not but
he screams that out when he's at the
line of scrimmage Dean goes three and
forty five to Omaha oh my god I swear to
god yeah and I have no idea what it
means in football or anything but maybe
somebody will write in and let us know
okay this is what Alex Betts wants to
know can a small black hole orbit a
bigger black hole and if so can it be a
stable orbit where it would never fall
into or merge with the larger black hole
all Academy black Google here right the
answer is yes
boom okay so here's the thing I don't
think a black hole knows it's a black
hole
really it's just a lump of mass out
there looking for love
okay that's all the wrong places now I
get the black part no so so the point is
so a way to answer that is if earth
today turn into a black hole right you'd
be a mini black hole like the size of a
calculator points about a plum okay oh
really yeah so you mean all of this
earth down the horizon it would be deep
within the plum right but the the the
plum is the size of our event horizon
with the mass of the earth yes black
hole don't play dude okay so before we
going further with this no I just
I know bear it work where's the space
come from too so as you're collapsing
why don't you run out of space inside of
what's collapsing okay you wanna you
wondering isn't there a point beyond
which you cannot compress it any further
yes okay yes all right Alex we're
getting back to your question I'm sorry
but and they just I just got to know
okay so there are various states of
matter okay okay
why why is a rock a rock because
something is preventing it from
collapsing right okay so what is it well
it's the forces between molecules and
atoms okay okay right so the electronic
forces they're called I got that right
that's why you hit we all have rights oh
no no why I can't put my hand through my
lady's chair correct okay correct okay I
got you Invisible Man or something
mother what's the what's the X minute we
could do that walls yeah I know
I know I know you're talking about
alright but go ahead so the alright so
now it turns out under high enough
pressure you can collapse that okay and
close down the gaps that are between
those atoms and molecules okay all right
now they get closer okay together right
okay
and you get something called electron
degeneracy that's what it's called has
nothing to do with its moral compass
okay of electrons right is that okay
so electron degeneracy they're so
tightly packed okay that you're trying
to cram electrons into the space of
other electrons and they don't allow
that
alright from quantum akwonton physics
okay all right so they keep their own
identity within the structure and then
we have matter out there that resemble
is called white dwarfs white dwarfs are
electron degenerate and they're
extremely dense mm-hmm okay why don't
you go further okay there's still the
gap between the nucleus of an atom and
the electrons themselves let's collapse
that gap and that is the biggest gap of
them all okay you know that that gap is
take a football stadium all right hey
and then put I don't know a a mustard
seed okay I think tiny tiny zoster Suzie
seed monsters he's biblical right but
let's take a like a poppy seed all right
put that in the middle of the stadium
right that's the nucleus and the outer
sides of the stadium is the orbits of
the electrons Wow atoms are mostly empty
space that's in the first do to
determine this his name was was JJ
Thompson and he performed the experiment
by firing particles through a very thin
film of gold gold you can hammer it so
thin you have practically one layer
thick so the atoms okay alright you can
it's very malleable is nice chemistry
term right make it really thin and he
fired particles and he's ready to see
them some bounce back
Carine to the left to the light in 99.9
man
and I presented him went straight
through like nothing was there and he
was the first person to realize that
matter is mostly empty space that's him
and the next morning he is rumored to be
afraid to step onto the floor getting
out of bed right that he might fall
through it Wow cuz he alone knew how
empty matter was so the next stage is
collapsing everything down and you're
cramming the electrons into the protons
because they're no longer can they
separate themselves alright but they're
not gonna occupy the same space anymore
they're crammed together if you combine
a proton and an electron what happens to
the charge it becomes what I don't know
alright Alexa that's a negative charge
the protein has a positive charge they
cancel out and what kind of how much
charge you left with neutral neutral so
you put them together you create a
neutron right okay so now you so you
don't have the electron degeneracy and
you have a pack a pack of neutrons that
is the densest matter that exists out
there that is not a black hole okay so
these are called neutron stars because
in my field we tell it like it is
yeah right and neutron stars that
rapidly rotate have magnetic fields that
call they pulse and radio waves we call
those pulse house lines all right that
makes sense the person who discovered
pulsars Anthony Hewish won the Nobel
Prize for it back in the 1970s since he
started a watch company little known for
people always taking our word exactly
well we got lucky where candy bar we
excuse me can we get some royalties for
that please okay the Mars bar I know
it's a family name but still I'm taking
it right all right hey hey you know many
car names are astronomically named
uh-huh okay there's like the the Astro
that's the name of a minivan that was a
oh my god there is an ass yes yes I made
a whole list I will do a whole show on
the cars okay car names all right show
all right I could do a whole show okay
that's it don't get me started don't
make me go there okay a whole show on
names of stuff that gets my from your
astrophysics yeah okay that's it promise
okay all right
so so now we're a pulsar okay now pulsar
that stuff is there so that's if you
take one of them how dense that is take
a herd of 300 billion elephants and cram
them into a thimble
holy crap okay alright so now you can
calculate how much pressure that makes
to stop it from collapsing further and
you calculate that and then you figure
out in a black hole the collapsing force
is even greater
damn so we don't know we got no physics
anymore after that right so in a black
hole it's denser than the density of 300
billion elephants in a thimble crammed
into a thimble
okay and just imagine trying to do that
ya know with you definitely need a
crowbar so Wow so yes you I can get you
to the neutron star density after that
it's all black holes all black holes all
black holes oh so now earth becomes a
black hole we just continue to orbit the
Sun the gravity between us and the Sun
is determined just by our masses our
maths didn't change right okay it's
still the same mass who cares if we're a
black hole right all right now if you
turn the Sun into a black hole we don't
care if it has the same mass right so
weird these mini black hole orbiting
bleep back hole and there you go great
so we just be orbiting the little mini
black hole that's all no we'd be the
mini black hole orbiting oh no I'm
saying if the Sun became a black hole we
would just continue to orbit that little
black hole but but we're littler so
we're the plum sized black hole right
the Sun is the big that's a big Gert
black hole right so so the point is the
reason why we see black holes have such
high gravity is they have high surface
gravity hmm but if you step the same
distance away from it that you were
before it became a black hole it's not
and nothing's gonna happen right just
that you can get real close to the
center of gravity and the power of the
gravity keeps getting the the force of
gravity keeps getting higher and higher
and iron iron iron so that's how that
works that's all the answer is yes the
answer is yes we gotta take our first
break when we come back more cosmic
queries black holes and
dark energon dark energy on star
Rebeca Startalk cosmic queries Chuck
nice that's right
the basic ingredients you me cosmic
queries star talk that's it that's it
let's take it from there let's take it
from there alright in topic again yeah
dark energy and black hole let's do it I
think I think I can get through that top
so far so good alright let's jump right
back into this with a question from
Facebook and Kent by dieter mm-hm
yep Kent people would you please give
like phonetics pronunciation guide for
Chuck yes okay yes this Reading Is
Fundamental with me to be honest I wrote
anyway he goes like this Chuck Chuck
Chuck please ask Neil if a black hole
can reignite into a star once it has
lost enough mass through Hawking
radiation oh no because if somehow the
black hole could stay the same size and
you pulled mass out right then I don't
know I have to think that through but
what happens as you pull mash up the
black hole gets smaller and smaller and
smaller
to be the appropriate sized black hole
for the mass that's left over okay okay
so that's what's happening that's it so
the black hole just continues to shrink
keeping all of its parameters sort of
black hole proper ah that's so that's
why gotcha that's it there you go
all right all right that's pretty cool
all right this is John but that's I mean
that'd make a good sci-fi story so
someone in the future figures out a way
to run do black holes I can turn them
back into sort of masses that they once
were right yeah yeah okay that's kind of
cool that let's do it that was you you
could do that you probably could just
create a black hole yeah once you start
controlling black holes they they will
bend to your whims and then the first
thing people do is weaponize it of
course if this is what humans do now
that's a great sci-fi
story instead of some stupid like Death
Star right like you actually have a
killer black hole no no that's they did
that in a Star Trek oh they did yes it
was this drill that would drilled down
to the center of a planet and then
dropped red matter and then it would
that's right planted into a black hole
that's right so yeah if they've been
there yeah damn what I have done late
I'm late I'm late on that one you're
right that was the red matter that right
again why destroy the whole planet
wouldn't you want to keep the planet if
you know if your enemies with who's on
the surface get rid of them by some
diabolical means right but keep the real
estate yeah what are you doing and it's
always about like revenge like you know
it's not gonna bring your wife and
children back okay get over it all right
here we go John felt ran a black hole
warp space-time around it yes a star
does the same yes what happened to the
gravitational well that the star has
formed if the star begins to fall into
the gravitational well formed by the
black hole does it dissipate at the same
rate as the amount of mass being
stripped or do both wells combine I love
to people this be some good this is so
good John you're just showing off that's
what's doing John John probably work
right here all right all right so
there's a lot too okay so if you think
of it as the classical distortion in
like a rubber sheet right the revelation
the rubbers nozzle so the black hole is
like a very deep hole in the rubber
sheet but everybody's got a dimple in
the rubber sheet okay okay you got you
have your own my own little gentle
little dimple right there adorable the
atom and huncle's depending on the mass
exactly depending on the mass determines
how deep the dimple is in the fabric of
space and time right
as you merge two dimples it's the black
hole if it's a black hole in a star if
the black hole begins to fillet the star
as black holes are known to do hmm
then its dimple will get deeper and this
the black holes and will get deeper and
the stars dimple will get shallower in
response to this welcome to cooking with
black holes today we're gonna fillet a
star go ahead that's a fillet I thought
you said way slay that's it you know
what that means
it means to disperse no no what's it
mean no I thought it meant like - no
pull apart it's to skin God you okay I'm
pretty sure to pull apart but today it
could be generally if you pull pulling
someone apart you would do it with the
skin first that's the outer layer so
maybe that could have led to your your
hypothesis that I listed to do this okay
yeah yeah he actually looks it up
instead of just going hey Siri play okay
here we go
to strip off the skin you're correct
so it's outer covering of right so it's
not really pull apart it is indeed skin
for stripping is skinning and then you
you metaphor it and it's like to
criticize or scold with scathing
severity ah okay you just got Flav Flay
exactly and here's another one to
deprive or strip of money or property oh
that's mine these are your outer right
boot remove exactly
that's better known as divorce so
divorce is a legal fly it's legal
flaying that's sweet all right so anyway
star is flayed by the bigger dimple of
the black hole yes and so if you Flay
that so the dimples change size relative
to the mass that has changed hands right
right so it is possible for the start to
flay the stark the for the black hole to
flay the stark completely so that it no
longer has a dimple and it
consumed all of its mass gots it and
then it is the sum of the two dimples
together that's it alright otherwise you
can have a star that's getting slayed
while it's orbiting the two and so you
have two dimples just in orbit what with
a slow change in the two and that's
until one just disappears completely
this is kind of fun to watch
right um you can imagine that right yeah
okay yeah there you go there you have it
so that's how it is
okay all right let's go to love marauder
going on you know how to pronounce that
how big of an impact does dark energy
have on my everyday life
none okay next question not always about
you love marauder
[Laughter]
okay so the thing is dark energy is this
is this mr. steel mysterious pressure in
the vacuum of space that's forcing the
universe to accelerate in its expansion
against the wishes of all the galaxies
and their gravity trying to slow to
thing down right and so so some people
thought of as an anti-gravity force cuy
one day harness it and make spaceships
out of it
it's so there's an interesting sci-fi
frontier there but what I can tell you
is because it's manifesting in the
vacuum relative to where there isn't a
vacuum there's not much vacuum here no
right so gravity and electromagnetism
and all these other things are really
dominating where you happen to be so no
there's no known visible or measurable
effect on anything you will do in your
life right so just just if you're not a
galaxy don't worry about right yeah it's
not a galaxy among other galaxies in the
expanding universe right just chill just
till chill on that that's I will add oh
no that no I won't add okay all right
there you go all right well there you go
that's it love marauder I hope that I
hope you find that sufficient
okay to continue your love exploits
right all right this is Brian bull and
he wants to know this does a black hole
still produce light or other radiation
that just can't escape the black hole's
gravity so yeah yeah there's a lot of
energy and matter inside of a black hole
so if you're in the black hole yeah yeah
he's probably right a zone like that no
place to go right it's got no place to
go
yeah and so it's all in there so now we
don't have direct evidence of this call
me and let me go get on this yeah yeah
you you report back then I want a full
report yeah my desk in the morning like
Matthew McConaughey in that string
theory movie interstellar interstellar
yes what I mean that string theory
interstellar intercept with the program
listen I'm gonna be medication it's
really bothering my memory all right so
yeah there's no reason why you wouldn't
still see light and other things inside
the black hole right right it's just not
getting out that's cool yeah I think
next one excellent excellent
all right oh you know what else you'd
see go ahead if you tried to look
outside the black hole you'd see all the
stuff coming in oh yeah Oh that'd be
really bright oh yeah that's kind of
cool Ashley yeah not a bad yeah the only
problem is you just be like don't come
in here there's no way down there all
right this is our YP thank you our YP
for just using your initials okay our YP
wants to know this goody that's his name
rip like yeah that's Britton Etten
that's cool rip wants to know this could
dark energy or matter dark matter or
dark energy is it possible to manipulate
it to use it as a fuel of some sort
so here's a problem mm-hmm dark energy
we don't know how to interact with it we
we just measure its effects on the
universe dark matter reveals itself to
us through its gravity
okay but it doesn't reveal itself to us
in any other way that we normally
interact so we can see its effects but
not what it is itself not in material
not material that's correct because what
T really what do you do you touch it
right you pinch it right you weigh it
right I mean you you put it on you grab
it piece of it put it on a scale you do
all this and dark matter in order to
have something oh you you're this person
called Chuck right because all your
atoms are all attached to each other
thank God
okay yes they're all there right Dark
Matter not only doesn't attach to your
atoms right
it doesn't attach to itself so as far as
we know there are no lumps of dark
matter out there little dark matter
planets right no dark matter galaxies in
the cosmos that is oatmeal there are no
lumps of dark matter I used to as a kid
because you would put raw lemon sugar
then the eat of like oatmeal candy but
go ahead sorry wow that was early
you were early out of the box with
granola yeah those are rolled another
world
Oh twister with dipped rolled in sugar
and take those boat meal of you rolling
some sitting eating yeah yeah so there
you go
all right yeah so yeah there's no we
have no way to harness it in that sense
that's if you if you can't grab it
because your hand goes straight through
it and it doesn't make itself given
itself any kind of density sweet so you
can't there's nothing you can do this
right so you can see it no no you can
see its effects you can see its effects
but you can't see it and you idiot
interact with it is literally invisible
Wow because because not only do your
molecules and atoms not interact light
doesn't interact with it oh my god and
light and molecules and atoms are all
related to each other okay they all
interact they all you reflect light
right some light goes through you like
but gets absorbed inside you like x-rays
go into your bones and they see this on
a map they shadow your bones shelves or
have a little more light than most that
was that's true
it's a very urgent call albedo I'll be
wait a minute have a word for that
albedo yes yes okay if you have an Obito
of one right you reflect 100% of the
light that hits you not to be confused
with libido what if you haven't albedo
have a libido of one that's albedo of
zero you absorb everything that comes to
there would be a blonde have a libido of
zero you are married or libido job to a
minute I don't know what it is but go
ahead I'll be them so the point is yeah
I'll be so so I'll be just it's a the
ability of a surface of something to
reflect light I'll kids off and it's a
percent so one would be a hundred
percent nice zero zero so the moon has a
very low albedo as bright as it can be
it doesn't reflect much light Wow
yeah it's like in the like 10% of the
lighters I forgot the exact number but
really it's absorbing most of the rest
of it
Wow yeah yeah yeah so um where was I all
I'm saying is if you can't grab
something and put it in a box you can't
harness it you can't what do we get we
don't know how to heart light right
there we need some other way that we
invent once we figure out what it is we
might be able to find a dark matter trap
how do you figure out what something is
if you can't interact with it I know I
know thank you
this is the longest unsolved problem in
astrophysics it's been with us since
1936 Wow
yeah dude that is amazing that is really
cool I'm just saying
so the guy who figures that out the
person-to-person you're right I
shouldn't say guy I just don't know how
to say I'm we're living in 2029 I the
person who figures that out that person
is gonna win a Nobel Prize time 10 yeah
the person who figures out what dark
matter is all right and and then we
ideally we can control it manipulate it
put some of the box that'd be cool nice
yeah all right yeah yeah we gotta take a
break okay all right when we come back
more stark our cosmic queries black hole
dai manage my energy when we return
we're back star Hulk cosmic we're yes
Chuck nice that's meeting it Chuck nice
comic thank you sir
yes that's correct very good so it turns
out we are like luxuriating in these
answers wait I will I will
executive privilege and say we will not
do lightning round excellent okay good
just continue to look your to continue
to bask yes then I in the cosmic
knowledge juxtaposed with cosmic
ignorance sweet and therein
did you just describe the two people who
are on the spot wait a minute what
anymore self-confidence here describing
something bigger than us okay okay all
right
all right it's the intersection of
cosmic knowledge and cosmic ignorance
that is the moving frontier of cosmic
discovery oh nice that's I love that you
should tweet that
go ahead yeah you should that's a that's
that's a quite eloquent and elegant at
the same time all right here we go
Martin Cuevas and Martin wants to know
this what would happen to the earth if
it came close or directly in contact
with a black hole the one being
hypothesized to be perhaps the planet
nine orbit so I didn't realize that
planet nine was actually pustule a
positive to be a black hole I thought
that's why they call it planet nine
because it's supposed to be this super
massive object that newly has the Kuiper
belt but it's new to me too is it okay
all right good did you say all right
good then I'm not alone I don't know
who's hypothesizing that we have
external black holes or but I don't know
right I don't if maybe it's uh maybe I
missed that hey man is that a new
development that morning edition when I
Astrophysical Journal you know but so
but it's still a fascinating question
and I think about this all the time oh
really yeah if earth happened upon a
black hole that was traveling through
space an encounter between earth in a
black hole earth loses gods yeah okay
right now because we know about this
tidal force that will stretch things
where the
of the earth nearest to the black hole
will experience a much higher force of
gravity than the side that's farthest
mm-hmm that means the side closest to
the black hole will pull towards it
faster than the side of the earth and so
you'll end up stretching earth okay now
the problem with the word stretch is you
know earth is not Gumby right or elastic
man I am Earth dammit I'm sorry it's so
it's not like it's an earth is not made
of rubber the earth is made of sort of
solid substance so if you're going to
stretch put under stress the solid
sphere that is earth earth will
basically begin to crumble okay into
smaller and smaller bits of rocks so
that you're looking at massive
earthquakes oh yeah but what happened
and tidal waves
oh hell yeah if you fall straight in
right oh oh so yes sir Earth's will
distort become more and more oblong
until the the the strength of the
materials can't hold that shape anything
anymore right and then it'll start sort
of crumbling apart and we call that
spaghettification is when you start
becoming this long strand but against
spaghetti is one continuous string right
right right whereas this will be a
stream of particles it's right a parade
of particles as they so is this net flix
occasion
instead of spaghettification how do you
get Netflix in there screaming now I am
going okay you have to flub one for me
you just material yes yes for me
spaghettification if I'm not mistaken no
I just popularized it really yeah it's
true I thought I thought you were I
thought you actually joined the tour no
no I I popular eyes it but the the it's
traceable to Martin Rees Martin sir
Martin Rees in fact he got it he's now
Lord Lord Reese that's a little full of
himself isn't he
I command thee I command thee to bring
me my spaghettification all right so all
right okay
all right well yeah do we answer that oh
yeah yeah so we just break up our city
here on earth it would just be an
interesting phenomenon to behold oh yeah
yeah that's cool man all right hey
Martin
it would break open the very hot liquid
core of the earth glowing iron nickel
ball of molten iron right yeah yes a bad
day for that's the air that's not cool
right on
all right let's go to Todd Tobin and
Todd says how does a black hole not
consume space-time itself and just go be
s crazy bat-crap crazy and destroy the
entire universe
why aren't black holes running amuck did
he say B C crazy
he said bat you know
oh yeah bat the bat but the bad word did
he say crap were decent yesterday s
words oh you were translating for us yes
yeah I think as your own sponsor you
know why because as your own censor
these little kids they write me and
they're just like listen to this and I'm
like well you shouldn't be started
trying to learn stuff and give up your
dream damn you was a joke people is that
one please go ahead but anyway yes so he
said BS crazy
bat-crap crazy and why aren't they why
are black holes running amok wait so so
he's saying why doesn't the whole thing
just like why aren't they out of hand
why aren't they just like consuming not
only oh I guess that's why so why are
they consuming space-time itself and
just just eatin the way the entire
universe
eat it away okay because black holes are
not any more voracious as black holes
than they were as stars before they
became black holes interesting so it's
really about mass it's just the man it's
just max that's all if you get now so
the thing here's how to think about it
think of the Sun okay before you how
close can you get to the Sun you get
near the surface ages vaporize okay all
right so now that the sun's surface its
atmospheric surface has a certain
strength of gravity there okay okay now
let's cram the Sun into a smaller volume
same amount of mass it's just answer you
can now get closer to the sun's center
of mass so it's service gravity is now
higher crammed it's smaller the surface
matter is even higher
black holes are fun to think about and
talk about because you can get close to
them if you get closer to Earth's center
of mass you leave in half of Earth
behind you and it's not interesting the
good thing of the fun thing about black
holes is you can get close to their
center of mass and their entire mass is
between you and their center that's why
they become interesting but puff it back
up to the original size there's no
different nobody cares all right that's
nice the black holes are just there
there they allow you to get close to
them without you knowing how deadly they
are in such a state oh my that's all oh
snap that's the difference okay that's
all right so and but technically an
ex-girlfriend like that they tell you
they are consuming the space-time around
them space folds back on itself so that
you cannot even come back
you can think of a black hole as
completely consuming the volume of
space-time in its vicinity I have no
qualms with you thinking of what's
inside the event horizon as the black
hole having having eaten its own
space-time continuum I have no problems
with that that is super cool right wow
what a great question then I mean and
there's that old ancient question what
happens if a snake starts eating its
tail mm-hm and continues to do so right
will the snake one day disappear I don't
know but it certainly won't be hungry
if it just keeps eating it wraps
yeah but then how does the head eat
itself it comes in from behind the head
okay if you imagine a completely
flexible snake right it just keeps going
and there you go yeah
that is the would make the end of the
meal and it's gone no more snake right
that's that's a black hole there you go
all right all right that's cool hmm all
right Christopher Karns Chiron's wants
to know this everything in space seems
to be spinning and rotating the Atlantic
spins and rotates around stars stars
just to be clear if you rotate on an X
if you turn on an axis so we say you're
rotating if you move around another
object we say you're revolving okay okay
so just just most people don't know that
but it's since the language can
distinguish it right why not right and
they're not weird words we've all used
them before okay so go so stars spin and
revolve around galaxies centers rotate
and then they revolve yes even galaxies
are spinning yes is there any evidence
that there are rotate that they are
rotating around something they spin but
do they rotate or revolve end up with a
new vocabulary revolved around something
else
so in our neck of the woods no wow okay
well because we don't have enough
galaxies where we
to be able to create an orbital system
right right now as far as we can tell
we're on a one-way collision course with
ladawna doesn't right we're not orbiting
each other anything like that all right
however there are places in the universe
that have hundreds and in some cases
thousands of galaxies in a sort of a
beehive configuration hmm
you can track those galaxies those would
have orbits around the center of that
galaxy super cool called super cluster
super clusters right so yes in in not
all cases but in some interesting cases
you do have stars that rotate orbit the
center that revolve around the center of
their galaxies as do all the other stars
in their galaxies and the galaxies self
is orbiting the center of the super
cluster yes now is it possible to see
the to see the movement of the galaxies
and measure in such a way that we could
possibly see if there's something there
revolving around like a black hole or
something that's at the center of the
super cluster oh you know centers of
super clusters that's an interest yeah
I'm sure that's from saying that would
be an early that would be really cool
thing to find out if the super cluster
is actually revolving around around a
black black hole itself yeah that's an
interesting question right I'll get on
that for you buddy but there turns out
you might ask could the super cluster be
orbiting around some other concentration
of some meta massive galaxies right
here's a problem you ready go ahead you
can look at the speed of galaxies moving
in the largest of the super clusters
because you can measure this with the
Doppler shift okay okay that makes sense
but we all know the Doppler shift
intuitively alright so for cars yeah
exactly you stand on the edge of a
freeway right oh that was good those a
Speedway that was yeah
okay so no one ever asked why doesn't it
sound the same coming towards you as it
does going wasn't no so so the pitch
changes okay what you teach here do I
love it okay so so it's a higher pitch
if it's coming towards you right at a
lower pitch as a cooler so it's like
compression and explain exactly that's
and so even though it's only giving the
same sound if the cars parked in front
of you
the engine is making one sound right
right side the car all you hear is okay
God so so you if you measure the kung-fu
movie ever if you measure the change in
the frequency of sound right as it comes
towards you right and compare it to you
can and you know what that sound should
be is a very simple formula that was
developed by Christian Doppler who was a
German physicist he might even been a
chemist actually but he was I think this
was a 19th century you figure this out
okay and he did it with a railroad train
that the whistle of a train as it came
by because they didn't have race cars
right right so you measure how fast the
galaxies moving and then you look at how
big the galaxy cluster is great you say
how long will it take at that speed to
cross the cluster that's perfectly
honest question and the words no okay
for the biggest of these cluster takes
longer than the age of the universe Wow
so the cluster has not had enough time
to have everybody sort of organize into
their orbits that's yeah so first many
of these measurements you can't use the
speed as an indication of other stuff
that's going on Wow
yeah yeah we don't live long enough no
no damn it I know at times like that
during the Super Bowl I tweeted that no
I did not you know you I've read your
tweets you don't read my tweets oh now
I'm embarrassed all I said was while
you're watching
if the hundred yards on the field were a
timeline of the universe okay
of the 14 billion year universe and in
one end zone is the Big Bang right and
modern day is like the other end zone
then the thickness of a blade of grass
the width of a blade of grass at the
other end zone is from 30,000 years in
our past to the present just one the
thickness thickness not not the width of
thick just just right the thickness yeah
cavemen to modern time that's our little
that's what we occupy well out humans
yes from so magnin cro-magnon humans
over that time so that's the entire
history of our species on a hundred yard
long football field so we're not four
computers to simulate what's going on
over timescales longer than we live we
would not know anything about things
that lasted longer than we do
damn oh yeah that's pretty wild and our
our ego historically was we are the know
everything so why should be much older
than our history directly right why
should it why should it when this is all
about us why should your eyes not see
things that are seeable in the universe
right when I'm the only one that matters
right so even the telescopes that were
first constructed only brought us
visible light right we said we have
better version of our eyes but it's
still like that we can see discover
infrared x-rays ultraviolet x-ray gamma
rays the whole rest of the spectrum you
can't see how dare the universe
communicate in ways that our senses
cannot detect you know what this is
really fascinating because it starts as
you look at the fact that we are indeed
one chromosome away from you know the
other apes yeah at the same time we're
the only or are we are other animals
thinking about this kind of stuff that
we're talking about right now are there
dolphins just like yeah I'm telling you
right now man there's something more
than this ocean yeah there's a well and
we got an end right like right now but
there's a comic that Gary Larson you
remember that's right he there's a
chicken a horse a a cow and some other
farm animal in the barn
way they're having a conversation yeah
okay and chickens sense but if you
divide by the square root of the mass
you get the same result and then like
the cow said but what you're missing the
basic premise of my theory and one of
them looks out the window
farmer okay these performers coming
towards them and the farmer comes it
right yeah that's so you don't know if
they're not talking that way when you're
not looking no I'm pretty sure they're
not it's like the refrigerator right
right you don't know if it's really
close all right we gotta go we went way
over time here this has been star talk
cosmic queries Chuck nice Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist as
always I bid you
[Applause]
[Music]